y'a un coiffeur qui propose gratuitement
à tous ceux qui le souhaitent de leur
faire la coupe de cheveux de donald
trump ou de kim jong-un
elle était ma témoin les deux photos
déjà été menées ont été déjà des deux
photos des gaffes et de photos que j'ai
sur ma fiche
ils les ont pas cette bande normal le
coiffeur c'est devenu une star aux
quelques jours regarder un coiffeur
vietnamiens basé à hanoï coup de quantis
à condition de ressortir avec la même
chevelure que donald trump ou que kim
jong-un
les clients qui se sont laissés tenter
par ce qu'il y en a doivent désormais
assumer
on s'est imaginé votre tête et vous
alliez c'est ce que vous êtes et quoi
vous ce week end au barreau castaldi
j'étais là dans le parc de la souris
parc de la souris à astérix métier dans
le parc avec mes enfants
alors regardez jamais méchant glisse
saïda un truc
ouais non non non on est en fait vous
êtes dégueulasse c'est pas mal
oui mesdames effet caen ce weekend je
suis allé voir l'exposition vasarely n'a
pas pu résister aux mazars et les a
compilées au hasard iac dans ce film des
inconnus oui bazar et moi je me rappelle
les trois frères la partie voilà ouais
c'est plutôt brac vasarely mais c'est
magnifique
ah oui oui c'est quoi il fait un peu ces
graphies gouaille et c'est ce qu'on a vu
de rester soixante dix années jospin
vous avez été dans une position encore
ben brik vasarely fait pas débattue la
plus tôt ouais il joue à l'inter de
milan avec kylie c'est formidable
j'étais avec mon amoureux patoche c'est
tout bah oui et votre fils il est avec
ses copains bah oui c'est un petit peu
immense ip celui-ci widgets
cinquante deux ans quand même
[Applaudissements]
l'exposition bazaris way ses boutures je
sais pas si c'est mon amoureux qu'a payé
mais ça doit être aux alentours de 15 12
15 euros c'est lui qui a payé il faut
pas juste des vases à sur les pédales me
regarder votre thé à l'épée d'ayew ça te
va bien et oui on sait très bien qu'on
fasse tous est tué
vous savez ça nous fait rire mais là bas
ils rigolent moi parce que c'est une
coupe obligatoire au corps ils ont le
droit en trois temps ils ont le choix
entre trois aux trois ou six dans trois
coupes de chacun par coupe de cheveux
son coin ça de faire 'document
différentes donc celle là vous vous avez
fait contre rennes bat dernière
tentative et que mon chien quoi c'est à
dire a encore qui se veut à et alors là
non raté poc regardez on a fait voter au
fait regarder lui sa venue à bout ça
chauffe ça chante c'est mal fait c'est
mal pris il sera ma chérie que très
bientôt dispo pour le club
obama série à marrakech ce week-end
encore ça fait tu m'avais vous aviez à
deux doigts de pécho moi j'ai dit ça
ouais ouais tu dis ça mais vu comment il
raconte tout n'était pas de droit de
pêcher dans la loge tard il vous est si
chiches de la vie politique alors et
donc vous avez fait à marrakech alors
marrakech me suis baladée j'ai fait un
peu de piscine voilà quoi vous êtes allé
comme ça pour le pour le clifa ben oui
pour le soleil pour la célèbre page
avait du soleil
non mais ça fait du bien de changer
d'ère un peu de temps en temps y'avait
pas balances ton poste pour une fois
vous avez payé les pays où vous étiez
invité non j'étais invité dans la villa
mais j'ai payé mon vis de mon billet
j'étais invité dans une bande-annonce
est allé à l'écrit noble métier avec qui
avec des amis un mail noms des noms avec
avec des amis ma famille ma fille
voilà on est tranquille y a rien du riz
oui j'aime bien pas de nom qu'un dos à
dos rien chine at gmail temps en fait
ouais moi c'était deux jours mais le
week-end prochain pour suivre le dossier
loïc viens de regarder c'est pas si mal
maxime gagné un petit mot tapé mon
maxime abbas étaient des nuits blanches
à agban larigot des nuits blanches ce
matin j'ai mis mon réveil à 3 heures du
matin pour suivre les oscars non merde
mon application my canal et hop
j'ai tout suivi dans sa grinta et
famille pour eux n'a pas dormi parce que
je me levais tôt pour aller dans un parc
d'attractions qui nous rend baba dans le
baby baby
oui j'en suis baba à walibi tout seul
alors je le garde pour moi parce que le
parc était fermé non ouais donc j'ai eu
l'ouverture quasiment de découverte pour
moi tenons à rappeler parce que je leur
fais quelques vidéos pour les 40 ans du
parc vertou la nouvelle fiction mais
voilà boulot alors des palm pre la non
mais ils m'ont appelé c'est ouf on ne
devait pas me kelly bas j'aurais adoré
on puisse parler de curation je t'invite
à mais non mais tu oublies toujours
kiffé dollars ça me désole
franchement je vous narre l a été je
trouve que c'est vous qui lui mettais
des bons à wayne rooney depuis ça fait
un an que je vais me servir et non en
fait
essayez l'album et nuit popa et l'autre
d'idées c'est toi qui n'a pas répondu à
hier soir mais je dormais mais avec
plaisir qu'on dit ça pour moi j'étais
pique-niqué au parc de morsang-sur-orge
ramener rosiers avec moi je t'ai avec
des potes et tout c'était trop cool
accord rosie c'est votre chien ouais bah
tiennent en fait on a oublié la photo de
maxime gainey s'est le mieux c'est le
mur qui me semble oui m et propose toile
est bonne autant ils veulent pas ça peut
aller bien oui vous on l'a fait qu'elle
ait ou pas on l'a pas faire d'annoncé
ont fait jamais calibrage et handball
trolliet gilles verdez remercie de par
jour
gillot si on arrive à faire si vous avez
fait vous ce week-end alors ses
week-ends love on viderait le conseil km
de marche rapide et je suis super
heureux photo est parti devant avec 100
m d'avancé et je les rattrape et au bout
de 9 km bah quoi mais son maître syrien
problème par à travers lequel ma belle
marché très vite elle aussi à tous les
deux à fond tous kilomètres le long de
la seine que tu n'as pas laisser gagner
par amour mais nord où lech avait gagné
11 kilomètres se sont pas parlé non pas
lors des derniers essais fatou qui
étaient contents et ont parfois ralenti
accélère et jean vous avez fait une
course tout les tous les deux absolument
11 km spéciale appréciez vous ce match
face à loeb le buteur retrouvé sa bopp
ça me fait sait plus quoi trouver pour
débarrasser lui j'ai une idée va faire
une marche de ce qu'ils auraient dû
peut-être 100 m l'avant elle fait elle
ne peut pleuvoir
bonsoir perdait c'est le même délire
alors oui vous commencez à vous ça va
très bien j'ai passé un week-end de rêve
complètement cyril hanouna compatible 3g
fait du poker et j'ai fait du tennis
ah ben ouais pour vous ce que vous êtes
donc un devoir on a toujours eu en tout
cas on a toujours eu les mêmes les mêmes
activités les mêmes hobbies on n'aime
rien en commun mais le poker et le
tennis on aime bien ouais mais ya pas
que ça où commence à progresser une
catastrophe quoi bein les goûts musicaux
les goûts de cinéma vous avez que dans
le bas vous n'avez pas le même goût que
moi à l'adil vous avez trouvez vous
parlez moi je serai avec vous mais vous
avez du goût mais c'est pas le mien
d'accord c'est quoi vous le dernier film
que vous avez aimé le bel le sim kallas
car justement greenbook boucle avec
viggo martin le livre vert wind book
c'est un très beau film vous devriez le
voir c'est un livre sur verre c'est quoi
l'histoire l'histoire c'est un lapin
c'est l'histoire d'un chauffeur ouais
blanc geoff hurst auteur s'il était
champion a pu appuyé sur le champignon
pour vous en parler bien qui appartient
un peu tort de mafieux italiens comme ça
et quoi chauffeur d'un homme noir
ouais ça parle du racisme aux états unis
on s'organise un très très beau film ça
a eu l'oscar ça l'acteur a eu l'oscar de
masculin du prix d'interprétation à ses
bienfaits oui c'est un très bon esprit
j'ai vu un film de louis xi 5,3 alors
moi ce serait plutôt qu'un mais ça n'a
pas été mais j'ai voulu attaquer
original ce que j'ai un petit peu une
nouvelle vie statham etc et dans la
bienveillance et l'amour et je me suis
dit faut que je sorte un peu ouais et je
suis me suis inscrit un truc que je ne
connaissais pas ça s'appelle soit gai et
cuisiner comme ne sais pas du tout
cuisiné comme toujours c'est vrai c'est
à bastille
donc on était 10 donc les gens étaient
un petit bond au début surpris de me
voir parce que je suis connue et puis
non mais c'est vrai une heure bien
qu'ils étaient là inconnu tout chacun un
métier 1
et puis je leur ai très vite expliqué
que malgré peut-être mon mon succès je
suis comme eiffage et le vis comme tout
le monde
somme toute donc j'ai pris des cours de
cuisine on a appris à faire des
financiers on en a on a papoté tous
ensemble c'était très agréable ça dure
deux heures c'est tous les samedis de st
oui on a changé un petit peu des numéros
donc j'ai déjà pris un numéro est alors
à sidra outre alors tu es alors quoi
alors bah alors j'ai appris à faire des
financiers puis le sport juin plantu et
ça s'est fait de le soir même vous savez
le la rencontre humaine parfois failli
fait de deux choses et fait du physique
et de la beauté intérieure
ce samedi c'était le physique et la
semaine prochaine je découvrais la
beauté intérieure de ça nous sommes
certainement pas très bien très content
de mon week-end cuisine bah merci et je
vous ferai les petits financier que je
ne mènerai à non vers son bien ah bon je
rigole pas à ce que demain j'ai pas peur
de manquer la fin oui mais il fera appel
les pointer en fait il va faire de la
vie à faire un pic d'accord dit qu'il
attaque où ces cerveaux pascal
mais en train de partir en cacahuète aux
talibans m comment ça marche ou ça va
très bien et ça nos minimes ou cadets
remercie 10 minimum être mon petit
préféré vous adore vous êtes le chouchou
de tout le monde
limoges est qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce
week end il a travaillé non pas ce
week-end enterrement de vie de garçon
d'un ami très proche
d'accord et à vous avez c'est quoi alors
des choses pas très intéressantes mais
j'aimerais dire que la première chose
qu'on pose comme question lorsque l'on
rencontre on parle pas de mathieu on
parle de kelly normativement bien sûr
comment est ce qu'elle est kelly est ce
qu'elle est sympa ça prend bien des
questions c'est pas vraiment vous donne
ci qui doit sceller sa part exactement
ce qu'elle est vraiment gentil non c'est
vrai c'est enfin et bach lycées beau
sans rigoler et alors vous dis toi à la
vérité oui elle est très gentil et que
les offres comme et personne ne parle de
mathieu donc lui qui nous dit
systématiquement j'étais pas là la
semaine dernière mon chéri à ce calme
toi vous a pas vous a pas dit me mom et
moi moi effet mois mais fait aussi en
plus élevé gable j'aime bien faire et
l'autre